- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna talk about one
of the most common ways
to measure solute
concentration in a solution.
And that is molarity.
And molarity is defined as
the number of moles of solute,
the thing that we are
dissolving in a solvent,
that divided by the liters of solution.
So let's just do an example
and see if we can calculate
the molarity of a solution.
So let's say that I have,
this is a container here.
And I'm going to dissolve
some sodium sulfate in water.
So sodium sulfate is the solute
and water is the solvent.
Together, they give us this solution.
And let's say we have a total,
the total volume of solution
is 250 milliliters of solution.
And that solution is made
up of just to give ourselves
a bit of a refresher.
We have the solvent, which is H2O,
it is water in this situation.
And you might say, do we have
250 milliliters of water?
And the answer would be not quite
because the 250 milliliters
that's the volume of the water
plus the sodium sulfate.
And so we're gonna have
some sodium sulfate in here.
And let's say we know
that we have 35.5 grams of sodium sulfate.
That is the formula for sodium sulfate.
And so given this information,
how do we figure out molarity?
Well, the first thing
you might say is okay,
I know the number of
grams of sodium sulfate.
I need to figure out the number of moles.
And to figure out the number of moles,
you'd have to look at the molar mass.
You could figure that out from
a periodic table of elements.
But just to speed us along,
I will help you out a little bit here.
The molar mass sodium sulfate,
molar mass is 142.04 grams per mole.
So given everything I've now told you,
see if you can pause this video
and figure out the
molarity of this solution.
What's the molarity of the
sodium sulfate in this solution?
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So first, we wanna figure out
the number of moles of solute.
So we can start with the mass of solute
that we have right over here.
So we have 35.5 grams of sodium sulfate.
And now if we wanna figure
out the number of moles,
see I'm gonna multiply
this times something
that would cancel out the grams.
And so I don't want grams per mole.
I want moles per gram.
And so I could write this.
I could multiply this
times for every one mole
of sodium sulfate, NA2SO4, we have 142.04.
I'll write this way,
grams of sodium sulfate.
And you can see very clearly
that that will cancel with that
and we're left with
moles of sodium sulfate.
So we'll get a calculator out in a second
and just take 35.5 and
divide that by 142.04.
And then to figure out molarity,
we wanna divide by the liters of solution.
So up here we have a
calculation for number of moles
and then the liters have solution,
250 milliliters is the
same thing as 0.250 liters
of our solution.
And now we can just use our calculator
to figure out what this is.
35.5 divided by 142.04 equals that,
and then we divide that by 0.25.
I could just throw a zero in there.
And then that gets us
that right over there.
And then we can think about
how many significant figures we have.
So we have three over here.
We have one, two, three,
four, five over here.
We have three over here.
So, I would say that we have
three significant figures.
And so we would round this right most
or this nine right over here.
Well, if we round that up, we get 1.00,
if we were to go to three
significant figures.
So that gets us 1.00.
And then you might say
what is the units here?
And what people will normally
say is this is 1.00 molar.
When you see this capital
M right over here,
that is the unit for more molarity
but they're really talking
about the number of moles
of solute per liter of solution.
And we are done.